this is what's called a failed print
last night at about 7:00 p.m. I hit the
print button and I got in this morning
at 10:00 and this is what I saw like
seriously I'm so cool
[Music]
Oh pooping again a screw was underneath
it it was just sitting there like this
that's the same thing that Freud here
yeah but why was that I don't see
anywhere else if we go z-axis is stuck
or the limit switch is broken I didn't I
didn't do that Sam's gonna be so mad
stuff just happens man it's not like
I'll worry about that in a moment
sennheiser has sent over some of these
mics and as you guys probably heard
about we got some very special ones
called the e9 one fours I want to test
not in a couple different situations
musical stuff holy stuff last but not
least filled recording stuffs want to
test out how powerful these things are
to start things off I'm going to put
these microphones and kind of an XY
configuration hitting a single point
here in the middle they're gonna be both
capturing very very different sounds I'm
gonna start with a guitar in fact it's a
special guitar isn't it he brought a
very cool 12 string guitar to the studio
today it's a great instrument to try
this effect on is because every single
string is doubled it gives it a very
bright and brilliant sound these strings
are either paired in unison or in
octaves
[Music]
ideally after the setup is done we've
got all this stuff recorded we'll leave
you with a beautiful sonic experience
I'm really amping this up I have a
feeling this is gonna sound really
really nice take one guitar clap sink
[Music]
so the drive stopped showing airs all
the smartdrive physical checks were okay
we did trace down to one file that was
corrupted you know maybe it seems like
page file corruption or some bad sector
on the disk or something that wasn't the
full on physical failure or rather more
isolated incident result of this is that
we're still on our main range well I've
run a bunch of Diagnostics
everything's of course all backed up do
we have to raise there's actually not a
straight-up raid10 system it's every
night one raid gets copied to the next
when the raid goes down just flip over
to the other raid and continue working I
think the only thing that makes me more
sad than a raid crashing losing all our
data people watching our videos who
aren't subscribed consider it it's great
you get all the updates right on the
nose right when they come out actually
no those are the people get
notifications if you turn notifications
on you get the note right when the video
comes up that's a little bell thing
right yeah you can get you like your
first comments I'm usually on there
reading will respond we just found all
the time on those comments so you know
it'll be super cool click that little
Bell notification thanks to narcos
cartel Wars for sponsoring this video I
mean what does a cartel anyway have you
ever thought about it I mean how does it
relate to the fact that today we're
playing the official game of the hit TV
show for season three premiere is a
cartel strictly a criminal organization
that engages in drug trafficking and
battles all of their organizations for
power because in narcos cartel Wars you
can build up your cartel in battle
against your friends or play a solo
campaign is the cartel updated regularly
with sicarios missions and features
because this game is but as it turns out
the word cartel doesn't just refer to
criminal organizations it's actually a
term for a type of economic organization
that's right see in strictly economic
terms cartel is just a group of
independent producers generally making
the same product who have agreed to
increase in collective profits by
engaging in price fixing or limiting
supply or other restrictive practices
now is that on American bet your acid is
you know what isn't taking what you want
I mean think of OPEC for example there's
a largest cartel in the world
OPEC you heard of them the organization
of the Petroleum Exporting Countries
they produce 45% of the world's oil and
they often agree to buy and sell their
product at certain fixed prices in order
to maintain global market conditions so
US cartel guys
we're not all bad going download narcos
cartel Wars for free on the Apple App
Store or via google play and join me in
battle may the best man win you should
wait til Sam gets in you hit your head
again
people problems just wait for Sam this
is an amusing Lehigh disaster
youtube.com slash Sam in the printer for
an hour threaten globbed it up do we
need a new part
you mean this new part sitting right
here this is great
this whole thing was caked in plastic
because this is the printhead this is
where they'd melts the plastic and
plastic comes out speak of the devil I
don't know what Ren was printing but
messed up real bad I turned it on he did
it up spent a while just picking chunks
out of it hard part was see how there's
plastic in here so you can pop this head
on the printer but need to be able to
raise up I heated it up got hot guys
much plastic ops I could once it's hot
this thing got a little gooey and melty
so this jammed it up push it up pulled
it out and worked its way out I also use
this all the katana for some extra help
looks like it should be in fully
operating order the rest of the thing is
fine the probably needs to be
recalibrated and however the back belt
is loose on the bottom so that means it
jumped a tooth we need to pop on this
panel saw loosen the pulley thing
tension will snap back into place should
be good to go
[Music]
okay cool well I wonder if a sonic
there's something in there just let's
save that and let's just take a quick
little sim for ourselves here and see if
this even sounds remotely cool I'm gonna
throw a lip cider compression
[Music]
real big so that's cool that worked that
works really well but special about this
is usually when you're writing and
recording music you very frequently
double track guitars aka you record them
twice and you put one on the left and
you put one on the right but sometimes
if it's a complicated part it's hard to
record that section twice identically
when you have a stereo setup like this
you don't necessarily need to double
track everything because you already
have that left and right it's super
sweet anyways I'm super jazzed about
that these sennheiser mics have done a
really good job of recording a musical
instrument and really quick I'm gonna
just try a quick Foley test yeah gun
reloads it's the best way to do it
thank you not normally what you need a
stereo fully sound because when you're
looking at objects from a distance it's
basically a single mono sound but in a
situation where you would want stereo
like if you're doing a close-up or an
insert or some detail shot recording
fully in this method could be pretty
helpful okay that probably sounded
pretty intense so this this airsoft gun
proconsul yeah that sounds really trippy
yeah this is like gun ASMR right now
it's kind of hurting my ears a little
bit because those clicks and pops are so
intense Foley works really really well
too but you'll have to be for specific
situations where that stereo sound is
needed and last but not least I think we
should probably try a field recording of
our own cool everything else should be
good I just see it tighten up the back
belt small victories man I can do some
tests and some calibrations Scott check
the leveling on the bed right did you
guys read level the bed well it helped
me out a little bit dude it's I'm trying
to pick subscribe Rayner I know you're
frustrated that broke but
okay so you didn't work with them at all
you guys then talk about it at all yeah
we do that any chance to try it out I
think he did yeah yeah okay to be good
I'll run some tests later today
Nico managed to get it working so the
problem what happened the bed leveling
screw had somehow fallen out cause in
the bed become misaligned printer had to
suddenly be printing on nothing spooling
out plastic or getting spaghetti maker
and that causes a staging of failed
events we managed to figure out
ourselves by ourselves I mean Niko's
selves three two one sink
okay so this is working out the way
right now
just here with the studio here is their
second dude Brenda like two pixels big
right now much better I'll be able to
share more about that soon but the thing
is this you know I'm spending a lot of
time on it I want it to be good before I
really share it don't rush anything that
you want to be good hey Sam and Nico Sam
and Nico dot-com youtube.com slash Sam
and Nico youtube.com slash Sam and Nico
yeah there we go
I love the idea of like yeah what do we
put over the swear words
youtube.com slash a meanie you dupe that
console singing you I can tell you that
much you do back on send me that okay
yeah it's a taut wire life is filled
with uncertainties sometimes you just
got to take a risk especially when you
can entertain other people in the
process
[Music]